l'invité du 7 8 avec Sonia Brot bonsoir
merci de nous recevoir ici dans votre
mairie à Saint-Cyr-l'École je le
rappelle vous êtes la mère de
Saint-Cyr-l'École il y a quelques jours
vous avez écrit au ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin pour
l'interpeller sur une situation je cite
infernale dans votre ville qui est
touché régulièrement par phénomène de
violence urbaine l'un des derniers
épisodes en date remonte à la nuit du 9
au 17 septembre dernier ou une vingtaine
de jeunes avec été au cœur d'une rixe
qui a fait quatre blessés dans votre
commune à quoi faites-vous face depuis
quelques mois quel est justement cette
situation intenable que vous dénoncez
alors très clairement nous avons depuis
quelques années une vraie difficulté
d'effectif sur la circonscription faut
savoir que Saint-Cyr-l'École dépend du
commissariat de plaisir donc civil dans
ces civils nous avons plaisir nous avons
Les Clayes-sous-Bois donc j'ai vu avec
des difficultés plus importantes et donc
petit à petit bien des situations de
ville plutôt calme ce sont dégradés par
négligence pas par négligence parce que
la police n'avait pas envie de venir
intervenir mais par manque d'effectif
on a vécu enfin juin dernier un épisode
de violence urbaine absolument
inouï que la France n'avait pas n'avait
pas en tous les cas de mémoire connue et
c'est une personne on est 21600
habitants
identifiés comptés à la météo à la vidéo
protection 31 et bien c'est 31 individus
se sont sentis tous les droits puisqu'en
fait entre les émeutes de fin juin et
Larix et nos interventions au niveau de
l'équipe municipale sur les plateaux
télé il ne s'est rien passé donc la
vérité c'est que nous avons eu des
émeutes nous avons eu deux jours où la
ville a été mise à feu et à sang où ces
personnes n'ont pas retrouvé en face de
réponses de répression et donc tout
l'été ils ont pu ainsi et bien crescendo
augmenter dans l'incivisme dans le
non-respect
de chacun
sauvage notamment ça a été tout le mois
de juillet et août du rodéo sauvage
alors avant on avait des
motocross maintenant on a motocross et
scooter Tmax généralement volé toujours
sans casque toujours en sens inverse
d'une route en sens inverse d'un
rond-point et donc une mise en danger de
notre population qui est grandissante ce
qui m'a amené
fin juillet apprendre la décision de
décaler les horaires de ma police
municipale et de les faire intervenir de
16h à 3h du matin d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour les remercier parce que
c'est pas évident plein plein de
vacances estivales de répondre à une
sollicitation qui remet en cause les
équilibres
ça aujourd'hui c'est moyen municipaux ça
ne suffit pas alors évidemment cette
police municipale je rappelle un peu les
montants parce que c'est pas rien ce
fonctionnement c'est 4 70 000 euros par
an
l'investissement pour le poste de police
municipale pour l'avoir en centre-ville
qui a d'ailleurs été détruit pendant les
émeutes c'est un million d'euros voilà
tout cet argent c'est l'argent de nos
contribuables c'est l'argent de nos
sincères de ceux qui quand ils montent
dans la voiture mettre leur ceinture de
sécurité et malgré ça
malgré ça fin août forcé de constater
que malgré les rapports avec vidéo à
l'appui avec
suivi à l'appui avec
des policiers municipaux qui sont
assermentés qui qui font des rapports
qui attestent il ne se passe rien et il
ne se passe rien pas parce que la police
nationale n'a pas envie d'intervenir
mais parce que tout le long de l'été et
vous l'avez vécu comme nous nous avons
assisté à
des refus d'obtempérer ou finalement la
police la police est mis en garde à vue
alors
voilà c'est quand même un scooter qui
rentre dans une voiture ben c'est c'est
sont les policiers nationaux qui sont
mis en garde à vue et donc il y a eu une
espèce d'impunité grandissante moi j'ai
vu revenir là des barbecues sauvages que
je ne connaissais plus depuis 10 ans sur
lesquels on avait beaucoup bataillé la
bataille était gagnée mais
vraisemblablement pas la guerre et donc
l'élément déclencheur pour vous c'est ce
phénomène des meubles suite à la mort de
Donald dans les Hauts-de-Seine il y a eu
je sais pas si la mort de Naël a chez
les émeutes
urbaines parce que en fait moi sur ma
ville j'ai pas eu j'ai pas eu des
familles en colère sur des violences non
j'ai eu des cases de magasins j'ai eu du
pillage j'ai eu de des
services publics qui ont été endommagés
je enfin en tous les cas moi je n'arrive
pas à faire le lien et cette situation à
votre avis elle est propre à Saint-Circ
à l'école ou quand vous échangez avec
des maires d'autres villes moyennes
c'est aussi une situation
à laquelle ils font face je pense et
c'est pour ça que j'ai interpellé le
ministre de l'intérieur c'est que si
c'était le cas de Saint-Cyr-l'École et
bien je me dirais que quelque part nous
avons raté quelque chose pas prier un
bon tournant la problématique c'est
qu'aujourd'hui je fais partie des rares
mères qui passent sur des plateaux télés
qui disent attention ces préoccupants et
clairement on n'a pas de réponse en
France la vérité c'est que ça touche
toutes nos villes quand vous prenez
l'actualité sur la semaine qui vient de
se passer vous voyez ça en Essonne vous
voyez ça
à Élancourt vous voyez ça dans des
villes où finalement on n'a pas que des
villes quartiers politiques de la ville
on a des villes moyennes plutôt
tranquilles nous on est sincère l'école
alors on a eu fait partie des des
quartiers politiques de la ville sur
deux quartiers on va pas se mentir on
est voisins de Versailles on est un peu
le fleuron avec notre école militaire on
peut pas dire qu'on est une
caractéristique de vie qui qui se prête
à ce genre de situation on a une
politique de prévention parce que nous
sommes anciens quartiers politiques de
la ville qui n'est pas négligeable c'est
à dire que en effet dans les quartiers
politiques de la ville vous avez des
éducateurs de rue vous avez bon nous on
n'a pas ces financements là en revanche
et à côté nous avons mis en place le
Pass jeunesse qui donne la possibilité à
nos enfants de 11 ans jusqu'à 26 ans
d'avoir moins 50 sur le cinéma municipal
sur le théâtre sur la piscine
nous finançons bien sûr nos associations
et nous les accompagnons de façon à ce
qu'elle puisse proposer un maximum
d'activités à nos jeunes que nos jeunes
ne restent pas inactifs et oisifs nous
fournissons des bâtiments municipaux
avec des gardiens c'est-à-dire du
personnel quelqu'un qui accueille qui
raccompagne qui qui vraiment intervient
dans la vie sociale au-delà des
effectifs ça peut être aussi une
solution le renforcer davantage
justement nous on l'a mis on a été au
delà c'est qu'on a même mis en place des
chèques associatifs pour qu'à la fois on
aide les associations mais aussi que le
citoyen l'usager soit acteur de cette
réussite d'associations de de ses choix
de ces demandes qui se portent avec la
possibilité il y a pas un enfant chez
nous qui peut dire je ne vais pas faire
du sport parce que j'en ai pas les
moyens voilà et ça aussi c'est une
réponse simplement forcée de constater
c'est que les personnes les 31 dont on
parle et bien ils sont pas intéressés
parce qu'on a mis en place dans l'une
des réponses de l'attendiez justement de
Gérald Darmanin vous le dites
aujourd'hui il faut des effectifs
supplémentaires sur une zone police ou
le commissariat vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure et situé à Plaisir aujourd'hui
il faut davantage d'effectifs qu'est-ce
que vous demandez comme effectivement
le premier volet c'est en effet des
effectifs supplémentaires parce que vous
pouvez pas faire la nuit avec un
équipage de 3 et
éventuellement une police municipale
quand j'arrive à décrocher des effectifs
soit si personne en face de 31 individus
c'est pas possible on ne peut pas
intervenir en sécurité ça c'est un
premier élément les effectifs c'est
important faut quand même savoir que sur
sur nos villes sur ces civils Saint-Cyr
après des habitants Villepreux a pris
des habitants Fontenay après des
habitants Bois-d'Arcy a pris des
habitants et on est sur des effectifs
qui sont
pardon mais pas à la baisse
le deuxième volet et il est important
c'est que notre police nos forces de
police puissent travailler en sécurité
moi je reprends ce qui s'est passé à
Élancourt et excusez-moi mais je suis
maire maire mais je suis aussi mère M e
r e et je me mets à la place de la femme
des policiers qui ont été mis en garde à
vue
en fait ces gens sont partis travailler
belle le soir ils sont pas rentrés de
leurs services et là maman a dit à leurs
enfants papa est pas rentré du travail
qui a conduit malheureusement à son
décès et à la mise en garde à vue de
deux policiers des forces de l'ordre
donc je me remets dans la peau de cette
maman et donc le soir je dis à mes
enfants bien non papa n'est pas rentré
il est toujours au travail lendemain
matin on sert le petit déj la papaye non
il est il est pas rentré j'ai toujours
pas menti il est toujours pas rentré et
puis le soir au dîner je leur dis bah
non papa est avec les collègues vous
voyez j'ai toujours pas menti j'ai
toujours une bonne maman j'ai toujours
pas menti à mes enfants la vérité c'est
que moi je sais qu'il est en garde à vue
et il est en garde à vue parce que quoi
parce qu'il a fait son métier
pire que ça je me mets à la place
si c'était
mon mari qui avait été dans la voiture
qu'il était pas policier et que
finalement dans le choc il était arrivé
quelque chose après d'effet du thème
nature c'est quand même normal qu'il y a
une enquête oui qui soit mis en garde à
vue
enfin pardon à un moment donné nos
forces de l'ordre ne sont pas des voyous
alors quand il y a une situation
préoccupante qui est une garde à vue je
suis totalement d'accord mais là en
l'occurrence
on a des caméras de vidéos protection on
a tout ce qu'il faut le message qui est
envoyé c'est qu'on a deux policiers qui
sont en garde à vue et un jeune homme
qui est en Marseille
tout ce qui s'est passé avant on en
parle pas trois volets quel était le
troisième volet
même s'il est écrit
au ministère au ministre de l'Intérieur
il touche aussi le garde des sceaux mais
j'ai eu longuement l'occasion de mon
entretenir avec lui de vive voix mais
aussi par courrier
Eric Dupont-Moretti c'est la réponse
pénale on ne peut pas mettre à feu et à
sang une ville pendant deux nuits
on ne peut pas avoir des services de
police nationale de police municipale
qui travaille qui identifie les
personnes qui sont capables de à la fois
donner le nom le lieu de domicile et
autres et se retrouver début septembre
avec 0 poursuite
davantage de réponse pénale face à ces
actes et rapides est-ce que le ministre
vous a répondu aujourd'hui à votre
sollicitation alors d'abord je tiens à
dire que cette lettre est partie le 29
août donc avant cette rixe qui a
finalement un peu
déclenché une horde de d'interview et je
vous en remercie parce que c'est aussi
une façon pour nous de nous faire
entendre mais voyez le 29 août on parle
d'une risque qui a eu lieu le 10 11 dans
un week-end dans la nuit du 9 au 10
septembre donc il y a quand même 10
jours d'intervalle entre les deux bon
le motif de ma lettre était pas d'avoir
un rendez-vous était pas mais quand même
à un moment donné de poliser les choses
et de les écrire
entre temps évidemment lorsque j'ai été
interviewé à plusieurs reprises j'ai
évidemment demandé à mon directeur de
cabinet de prévenir le ministère
parce que c'est républicains parce que
c'est normal et depuis nous avons un
rendez-vous qui a été calé avec le
directeur de cabinet de Monsieur le
Ministre que je remercie mais ce que
j'attends c'est
c'est des réponses et je suis ravie
d'être reçu à Beauvau et c'est
magnifique mais ce que j'attends c'est
des réponses en tant que mère
aujourd'hui sur ces sujets ce sera ma
dernière question vous sentez démuni
alors je vous rappelle que sur ces
sujets je ne suis pas compétente on
parle de l'ordre et de la sécurité c'est
un sujet qui appartient à l'État c'est
du régalien évidemment que nous les
maires qui sommes la petite république
comme dirait Gérard Larcher oui nous
nous sommes partis prenantes nous
mettons en place des polices municipales
qui normalement moi j'ai juste besoin
d'être simple pour faire traverser mes
écoles c'est tout ce qui m'incombe et
encore même pas donc voilà donc oui nous
sommes concernés oui nous nous mettons à
disposition et quand je parle de nous je
parle à la fois de la municipalité telle
que Saint-Cyr-l'École mais aussi de
Versailles Grand Parc avec un
déploiement et un investissement
important au niveau de la vidéo
protection mais aussi du département qui
nous accompagne donc voilà je pense que
les collectivités jouent le jeu
on peut pas nous laisser seul face à des
situations qui dont nous n'avons pas la
compétence et il faut répondre à nos
concitoyens parce qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans une situation où on apporte
pas de réponse et une fois de plus je
vous le dis
nous sommes 21600 ils sont 31 la
majorité de mes sincériens ils ont un
disque bleu ils mettent leur ceinture de
sécurité ils sont assurés au niveau de
leur voiture et ils ont un comportement
de citoyenneté qui a qui est assez
remarquable merci Sonia Brault merci de
nous avoir reçu ici dans votre mairie je
rappelle que vous êtes maire de
Saint-Cyr-l'École merci à tous de nous
avoir suivi dans le 7 8 qui touche à sa
fin belle soirée sur TV 78